how much are they making off these
facilities now like when they sell that
power uh to somebody who would come and
hook up to it are they really making
that much are returning like three four
cents a kilowatt hour or like what does
that look like so the landfill I know
that can be a substantial monthly
revenues that can be tens of thousands
of dollars coming in every single month
to a land for loaner so for them and for
the Bitcoin mining unit it's Alchemy
it's turning trash into digital gold
all right guys bang bang I've got Daniel
here with me Daniel I thought a great
place for us to start this conversation
is this idea of reducing methane
obviously there is a ton of talk about
climate change there's a ton of talk
about the science behind it who's
causing the rise in temperature and all
of these different kind of environmental
issues you're unique in that you are a
ESG analyst you're somebody who looks at
these issues and wants to help solve
them but you also are a massive
proponent of Bitcoin mining let's maybe
just start with how do those two worlds
intersect and why do you believe that
Bitcoin mining can actually help to
reduce methane and address some of these
ESG concerns well thanks Bob great to be
here I was a climate Tech investor I had
been a climate Tech investor for around
four years now so run two different
funds and there came a point when we
asked ourselves the question are we
doing enough through our funds uh and
the answer was no we realized that we
were only looking at carbon dioxide
emissions that's not our Indian mission
number one number two we were funding
Ventures that were high risk of course
so some of the technology might never
see the light of day and the other issue
was that even if they did see the
lighter day it was going to take until
well after 2030 before they achieved
scale so we started to ask ourselves the
question what can we do that's
mitigating not only carbon dioxide but
methane
which the United Nations is telling us
is now our number one lever to slow down
climate change number two what can we do
that's actually low risk so it's using
technology that exists today to find
climate Solutions
and number three
it's going to be very fast acting so
it's something that can happen before
and using existing technology and
mitigating methane we did a lot of
research and long story short we came to
the surprising conclusion that using
Bitcoin mobile mining units on landfills
was going to make a whole stack of
difference to mitigating our methane
emissions
so when you think about mitigating that
I think uh is something people say that
sounds good right like I I think that we
should mitigate the methane uh emissions
and and um let's go do that but you all
also think that Bitcoin potentially
become negative emissions which is this
really unique idea describe how we get
from something where people are
concerned about Bitcoin mining and they
think it's bad for the environment to
potentially being one of the only
Industries in the world that could claim
negative emissions
yeah it's fascinating so the first thing
to understand is why methane and how
that can make a contribution
substantially so for a long time now
organizations like the environmental
defense fund uh the EPA has said that
the best way to reduce landfill
emissions is by basically doing some
sort of power generation with them so
rather than what happens at the moment
is methane is 84 times more warming to
the Earth over a 20-year period than
carbon dioxide
so it's that's why the United Nations
has said it's our strongest labor to
reduce climate change over the next 20
years so the problem is
uh and just to give a context for
landfills so there's three big providers
of methane to the atmosphere that come
from Human sources so it's agriculture
oil and gas industry and landfills and
until recently we've thought that
landfills was our number three issue uh
well that was until last year when the
NASA jet propulsion unit from Pasadena
gave us the results of six years of
satellite footage and they showed that
our landfill emissions were
underestimated by a factor of 2.27
. so what that means is landfills is
actually our number two source of
methane emissions and then if you factor
in the world bank has said that they're
increasing at a rate of around 1.4
percent per year that's faster than
agriculture they're actually going to
overtake Agriculture and be our main
methane Source by
2032. what is happening inside of these
landfills right in terms of like what is
driving it are we just taking trash and
we're throwing it in there and Nature's
kind of ticking over or is there some
process that we're running what's
happening
okay so what's happening is so when
organic waste decays it can decay in two
ways if it decays in the presence of air
then it produces carbon dioxide but it
produces if it decays without the
presence of air so in a landfill when it
gets very compacted there's no air
available then it decays anaerobically
which basically just means without air
and that produces methane and that's
particularly bad remember because
methane's 84 times as warming so what's
happening in these landfills is you get
huge amounts of inorganic and organic
waste piling together getting compressed
there's no Oxygen available you get
massive builds up of methane and that
methane for the most part at the moment
around the world is simply getting
vented into our atmosphere and it's
causing climate havoc
do we get to negative emissions if
landfills are growing at this 1.4
percent and it's the second largest uh
kind of culprit
there's a couple of ways you can do it
the first way is what people have
started doing is just simply burning it
so you put up what's called a flare
stack you've probably seen them on oil
fills oil fields so they exist on
landfills as well
so on a landfill you put up a flare
stack and it just burns the methane
there's a couple of problems there
number one it doesn't burn it completely
so it only destroys around 90 of the
meat saying the other 10 still goes into
the air but the bigger issue is these
things are expensive to point up and
you're actually turning a source of
power and you're just wasting it so a
much better option is to use that and to
generate power with it now what happens
there is typically when you produce
power so what that means is you get a
generator on site you purify that
landfill gas turn it into biomethane you
use that by a methane to go into a
generator which converts into
electricity now the problem is what do
you do with that electricity now in some
cases you can sell it back to the grid
but in the US for example and 70 of the
cases it's just not economically
feasible to sell it to the grid because
the grid cannot take it it would need a
major substation upgrade and so these
landfill owners going well I want to
destroy my methane I would like to get
some money for it if someone will pay me
for the electricity that I can generate
using that methane but my only options
are I can't sell it to the grid so I've
got to get someone who wants to set up
shop on site and I'll answer I don't
know about upon but I don't want to set
up my business on a landfill I don't
know a whole lot of people who do and so
one of the few people in the world who's
at she prepared to go that extra
distance
and actually set up a business on a
landfill is a Bitcoin mobile mining unit
so it's a very unique sort of
business that is able to take itself
anywhere and utilize the stranded energy
and because Bitcoin miners their major
cost is electricity
they care about this more than anyone
else valtricity is only five percent of
your operational costs you're not going
to bother but if it's 60 plus say that
it's for Bitcoin miners you go to the
edge of the Earth to try and hunt out
cheap sources of electricity and this is
why that these Bitcoin miners have made
ideal users of that landfill gas methane
turn into Power to create electricity so
it's a really natural Synergy how much
energy or electricity could be generated
from a landfill obviously the different
sizes of landfills get you different
numbers but like on average are we
talking about being able to run two or
three Bitcoin miners uh are we talking
about being able to run a warehouse full
of ten thousand like give us some
numbers or some way to think about this
so an average landfill will be able to
generate up to eight megawatts so one
megawatt you're probably talking around
about 300 Bitcoin mobile moments so you
multiply that by eight so what's that
two and a half thousand Bitcoin miners
operating so it's starting to get like a
mid-sized Bitcoin mining operation
coming back to that question just around
the the carbon negative emissions why
it's carbon negative is basically now
what you're doing is you're not using
solar or wind which is has
um zero generation based emissions
but you're using actually a source of
pollution as your source of energy which
is astounding there's very few
Industries in the world that can do that
you're using methane which would have
gone into the atmosphere
and you're stopping it from going into
the atmosphere so a real distinction if
you're taking it from a natural gas
pipeline
um then that would have stayed otherwise
in the ground so that's that's not
carbon negative but if you're taking
methane that would have gone into the
air you're stopping it from going into
the air and you're using it to generate
electricity then that's actually
emission negative and how much do we
need to do this to get to negative
emissions is this like we hook up two or
three landfills and we're good do we
need to do it uh a hundred on every
continent like what's the size or kind
of the scope of uh how big of an
investment this would be and kind of how
big of an infrastructure project are we
talking here
we're looking at 280 megawatts so what
does that actually mean again if you
think about an average landfill is eight
megawatts so it's about 30 to 40
mid-sized landfills is enough to do it
depends a little bit on the landfill it
depends on the geographic area sometimes
it may need to be a larger one but it's
not a humongous amount of landfills it
is absolutely feasible and the good
thing is that if we look globally we
have the potential like if you look at
the maximum just available potential
there's upwards of 15 gigawatts of
energy that could come from landfill gas
so this is actually a relatively small
amount of the total available landfill
gas power directed towards Bitcoin
mining and to put that in context so
right now
in the oil and gas industry there is
upwards of 160 megawatts being used from
what was previously fled natural gas
from the oil and gas industry so it's
not that much more than we're already
doing in the oil and gas industry we're
simply doing it with landfills and
there's a bit of an extra infrastructure
to put in place for gas capturing
collection systems
when you see this opportunity there
would be someone who would say let's go
build a company let's raise money go
build the infrastructure own 100 of it
or as much as we could maybe use some
debt and do it as a corporation you all
seem to be taking a little bit of a
different path where you're looking at
it much more as from an investor seat
raising funds to go and deploy and kind
of fund other people who are doing this
what are the pros and cons of doing it
as a company versus as a fund manager
well if you're going to do it as a
company you really want to be a Bitcoin
mining specialist and you have to go
deep down that rabbit hole we are not
Bitcoin mining Specialists we know a bit
about Bitcoin we know a bit about fourth
thing well I personally know a bit about
four things so to do a fund like this
you basically have to know a little bit
about Bitcoin money economics you need
to know about infrastructure Finance you
need to know about landfill gas power
gin and you need to know about how
carbon credits works on landfills as
well so we've looked at these four
different areas and we said okay that's
actually quite a lot to understand and
synthesize it's too much for any one
person to really have deep domain
expertise but if we build a team that's
specialists in these areas which we have
done
now we can actually start to move ahead
as a fund and we can have more impact
and for the last four years I've worked
out that when you're a fund manager you
have the ability to deploy Capital to
multiple projects in parallel that's
just something that has a lot of
personal appeal to me in terms of the
amount of impact you can have
so for me it was just all about how can
we have more impact sooner
now when you look at funding these
um let's say that you get 30 or 40
landfills around the world how do you
think about decentralization versus
centralization we saw a bunch of minors
leave China kind of unplug move
elsewhere the US was the big winner
Texas I think now has 10 or more of all
mining the United States is somewhere
around a third around the world do you
think that this is more decentralization
or could this actually lead to a higher
concentration in Bitcoin mining
definitely going to be more
decentralized because landfills by
definition are decentralized and they're
all around the world and so what's
the big factor about whether a site is a
good candidate or not has nothing to do
with its proximity to a major population
Center
obviously you need a sufficient number
of people there's a sufficient amount of
waste
but these things are all around the
world and it has to do with factors
which are very diverse such as
how humid is it for example humidity is
bad for Bitcoin mining but it's really
good for creating landfill gas and so
geographically around the world you look
at these different areas and it's not
necessarily in the places you'd expect
it's not always in the major population
centers
because they may have already turned
that landfill into a source of power
generation and it may have been
economically viable in Los Angeles for
example 50 megawatts that's already
selling power back to the grid so
typically the major cities they've had a
big enough landfill that it does make
economic sense to sell power back to the
Grid it's normally the next level down
the smaller cities where this has not
occurred and so it's a lot of those
mid-sized landfills that we're going for
so I actually think it's going to lead
to a lot more decentralization let's
talk economics how much for one of these
mid-sized landfills will it cost to get
the methane into electricity build out
the Bitcoin mining facilities and be
able to actually mine Bitcoin are we
talking on the order of magnitude of a
couple million dollars tens of millions
hundreds of millions billions of dollars
what does it look like
yeah for a mid-sized landfill so around
eight megawatts you're looking at 10 to
15 million dollars
and so if you want to do that let's call
it on 35 about 350 to 400 million
dollars you think that we could
basically do this in a decentralized
fashion and turn for less than half a
billion dollars Bitcoin mining into a
negative emissions industry which would
then put it at the Forefront of the ESG
conversation that's correct
now when we look at other solutions to
address climate change and kind of ESG
concerns there's a recent story that's
come out around paint and the ability to
put white paint uh on the ground
um so if I read it correctly they think
that as simple as just like go paint
half the Sahara Desert uh which again
put aside the logistics and and the
approvals and people's willingness or
appetite to go do something like that
um but one of the main arguments is how
inexpensive that would be to address
some of this I think that what I've read
and again you are an expert I am not on
this
um we are talking about trillions of
dollars is the current estimation to
address uh kind of climate change in
general
I don't think you're saying Bitcoin
mining with less than half a billion
dollars could address all of climate
change but what you are selling is that
it would lead to a negative emissions
for this specific industry and so Not
only would it negate or mitigate the
current emissions it would actually make
it this positive story are there any
other kind of parallels you can draw to
like half a billion dollars or less
investment and it has this massive
impact or do you think that most of the
ESG industry is just kind of bloated and
they throw out these huge numbers but
like maybe people don't actually
understand how much this is going to
cost to do
yeah would you give some context so a
couple of companies that I've invested
in previously so the maximum that they
could ever
mitigate in terms of emissions one of
them was 10 million uh tons of carbon
dioxide equivalent the other one's 20
million tons of carbon dioxide
equivalent and it would take around 15
years and that was absolutely best case
scenario that's Global Monopoly in 15
years which almost never happens in the
tech industry
so with using Bitcoin mining we can
mitigate 4 million tons in the first
year
just with five landfills
we can achieve that within two years
what it with previous technology
companies I was investing in would take
15 best case scenario
so so definitely in terms of one of the
markers of success for this fund we said
we want to
maximize the amount of emissions reduced
per dollar invested so that was our
starting thesis so we didn't start with
Bitcoin and then try and rationalize why
it was good we started with saying let's
maximize the emissions reduced per
dollar invested that led us to landfill
gas uh firstly it led us to methane
secondly it led us to landfills and
thirdly it led us to saying you know
what it's actually going to be on-site
data centers that are going to be the
best way to do this and the best data
center that Stacks up in terms of
economics right now is going to be
Bitcoin mining data centers
so that's how we got there
in terms of what kind of the days that I
I haven't looked into that um you've got
to remember I'm a climate Tech investor
so I tend to be naturally skeptical of
anything just by disposition because you
have to be however
you shouldn't
um
dismiss something just because it sounds
implausible and so that particular
suggestion who knows uh it could be a
pie in the sky idea with a technical
obstacle that no one's discovered yet or
it could be a brilliant solution so what
you've got to do with Solutions like
that you just keep an open mind and you
go through very thorough due diligence
in the meantime
to give some context I've come across
probably around 200 different climate
tick ideas including some ones which
sounded wonderful and
at some stage in the due diligence
either for some technical reason or some
commercial reason you found some bag and
it wasn't quite as effective and it
wasn't Magic Bullet everyone thought it
would be and I've gone through that
process a few times
so I would look at this in the same way
I'd be open-minded to it but also I
wouldn't be uh changing the direction of
our strategy for mitigating climate
change until we've thoroughly done due
diligence on an idea like that what's
the role of government in all of this I
think the State of Florida is home to uh
the largest number of solid waste
combustion facilities uh anyone who
listens to this podcast will be like
pump definitely read that on the
internet somewhere and I did in
preparation for this conversation but
given that they have so many of these
specific facilities is it something
where you need either government
approvals or government participation to
kind of accelerate these plans or can
the private sector do it without the
participation or Partnership of the
government
so it involves local government so
typically you're dealing with
municipalities so Municipal Solid Waste
so it doesn't need central government
approval doesn't need federal government
approval
um it needs participation and enthusiasm
definitely you want that but the
relationships are with the
municipalities having said that in the
future I believe that to do this really
well it would be advantageous to have
the buy-in of central government and of
local governments as well for a very
simple reason and that is long term we
don't really want to be doing the
financing of the gas capturing
collection systems it would make much
more sense for us to do Partnerships
with government where we said look
you've got a vested interest in reducing
emissions we have a solution which can
help you do that can bring back money to
local municipalities
is good for the community it's good for
the local environment it's good for the
global environment
you fund the component at something like
20-year treasury rates for the gas
caption collection and we will fund the
Bitcoin mining operations so we could
see collaborations such as that that may
occur in the future
how much are they making off these
facilities now like when they sell that
power uh to somebody who would come and
hook up to it um are they really making
that much are returning like three four
cents a kilowatt hour or like what does
that look like and then what is the
potential
um you know economic upside with Bitcoin
mining and really what I'm trying to get
at is like eventually are the
municipalities incentivized just to do
this themselves as they can figure out
kind of logistically and expertise wise
how to do it
yeah so if you look if you exclude
landfills and you look at some of the
cheapest available sources of
electricity excluding landfills
um I I've seen as cheap as 25 a
megawatts so 2.5 cents per kilowatt hour
and so if you're going into landfills it
has to be a whole lot cheaper than that
again because you can't just it's not
like a solar plant or uh hooking up to
the grid you can't just do it
immediately you've got to invest some
infrastructure is going to be delays so
typically it's going to be around half
that level of the cheapest available
otherwise but for the Lancer liner that
can be a substantial monthly revenues
that can be tens of thousands of dollars
coming in every single month to a
landfill owner and remember they don't
have to pay anything to achieve that
Revenue either so it's simply a
negotiation where you make sure you set
up your site in a way which isn't going
to interfere with the heavy machinery
you go and do your thing they are
mitigating an environmental problem
which is positive for them because it
keeps their regulator off their back
and they're getting a source of money
that otherwise they wouldn't have access
to because remember we're targeting
landfills which have no option to sell
it back to the grid so there's no other
competing user for that electricity so
for them
and for the Bitcoin mining unit it's
Alchemy it's turning trash into digital
gold
when the governments start to get
involved in this
um there is this weird balance of uh you
need them they have usually control of
the facility they have in some states
subsidies or or ways that they can
actually change the economics and the
people who are converting the waste to
the energy or the people who are going
and taking the energy and kind of
consuming it
um
but also there's this weird dynamic of
like Bitcoin kind of was built outside
the system Bitcoin was uh you know to
some degree
um a parallel system
how do you balance that in your head and
like are there risks maybe
um with that public-private partnership
that you guys have identified uh or
maybe even on a broader standpoint you
know kind of the the ESG conversation
and and the people in that industry with
the bitcoiners I don't think most people
are like oh those people obviously all
get along and you know get in bed with
each other so like how do you think
about risks or challenges with some of
the the more kind of soft skill weird
things that are that are at play here
yeah you're absolutely right there's a
lot of people who are going to come
together who may not naturally uh be
people who meet with each other and do
business with each other so again we see
it a couple of ways firstly with the
municipalities if you look at some of
the companies out there such as nodal
power such as fishbein who are doing
great work already the EPA you know
really like what they're doing because
they're solving a problem for the EPA
and that problem is that they
drastically want to reduce methane
emissions but there's been no good way
to do that
and so for The Regulators for central
government it's they recognize
particularly the people who are in the
Environmental Protection Agency that yes
whilst they're regulators and yes they
do have the stick called we will find
you or we will regulate you if you don't
do that they'd rather not have to use it
they would it's much easier for them if
there are economic incentives so A
Private Industry can come in and offer a
carrot that's much better than them
having to use the stick and they know
that and so that's why they've been very
supportive of these sorts of on-site
power gin possibilities so I actually
see some natural synergies with
governments where we're solving problems
for central government which otherwise
would go into the too hard baskets
and it's done in such a way that it's uh
it's actually stopping regulation so so
I see this as positive and the other
sort of Regulation rule stop is by
partnering and working in a Cooperative
Way by central government then it really
takes a lot of the steam out of the
whole emphasis for some more Draconian
regulations which have been proposed for
the Bitcoin mining ecosystem because if
the White House for example has said
look we like this idea of using methane
and
destroying it in order to power Bitcoin
mining and they have said that in their
report
and then they see some evidence of that
actually occurring they've also said in
the White House ostp report that if more
of this occurs in this area that would
help give them comfort that Bitcoin can
be a net positive for the environment so
once they have the White House has been
it in some cases very critical of
Bitcoin mining they have also said that
we're open to being dissuaded we're open
to seeing other ways we can see evidence
these strong movements that are a
climate that are positive for the
climate then we can change our viewpoint
on this so I think there's a chance for
cooperation here
talk not only about the infrastructure
like you were mentioning earlier you
know when you generate waste to energy
the energy is hard to move right and
sometimes the grid can't take it because
there's a surplus and and there's things
that we've talked about in Prior
episodes uh with people on this podcast
I think the audience probably
understands now like it's really hard to
move this energy but also not just
moving the energy Bitcoin mining
provides a persistent buyer of energy
and so how does that kind of plan it's
almost like this like beautifully
designed thing that people kind of
discount or don't understand the
persistent buying or persistent demand
is maybe one of the most important
components to being able to help solve a
problem like this
definitely
if you've got someone who you know is
going to buy energy 24 7 whenever it's
available
um that's the best sort of customer you
could possibly get particularly if they
don't care about moving to where the
energy is so whether it's a landfill
whether it's a new Wind Farm whether
it's a solar farm one of the biggest
problems you have is you're in the wrong
place geographically
it's not easy to hook up to the grid and
even if you do hook up to the grid
you've got to transmit power a long way
so again
what Bitcoin mining company is doing not
just what landfills but with solar farms
and wind farms as we're seeing them come
in early
and we're seeing that even for example
let's take solar farm before it gets
connected up to the grid you've got a
major problem right now first problem is
how do you get funding
and you know as someone who gives
funding to infrastructure I'm unlikely
to give funding to something if your
value proposition is it's going to take
me 3.7 years to get grid interconnected
and in the meantime I've got no revenue
and I want a whole lot of money
but if I must to give funding to
something and it's now a solar farm and
they say we've got our first customer I
say okay I'm listening
and they say yeah and they guarantee us
a steady price at this base level so
there's a floor price established for
that electricity I'm saying okay I'm
listening more and they say and they
want to buy our power whenever it's
available
and by being that customer now I'm
looking at an equation and suddenly the
economics are starting to stack up I'm
much more likely to fund it
so having a constant buyer of that
electricity who doesn't mind when and
they don't mind where so in other words
the location agnostic
and they are time of diagnostic as a
tremendous advantage to whether it's a
solar farm a wind farm or a landfill or
any sort of potential power provider and
we'd never had a customer like that ever
in the history of the planet and a lot
of people don't realize just how unique
Bitcoin mining is because of these
accidental features where it doesn't
care when and it doesn't care where it
locates to get that electricity and I
think the third thing is people don't
realize is because we've also never had
a user where their electricity costs are
such a high percentage as the total
expenses and what that means is that
you're going to do everything in your
power to get cheaper electricity
that makes you the ideal customer of
anyone who provides electricity because
the value proposition of getting that
cheaply is is just so important to you
it is your core business when it comes
to the expense Side Of The Ledger so
it's going to incentivize not only a lot
of these landfalls been mitigating the
methane it's also going to incentivize a
lot more renewable energy getting onto
the grid sooner getting funded better
and then when it's on the grid of course
we already know the story here it's
helping with the load balancing and
reducing curtailment
before I let you go talk to me about CH4
Capital
um you all obviously have a a very
specific point of view in the world how
do you think about that firm and
allocating capital in the way that you
guys do
yeah so we had to make a decision a
little while ago about whether we went
very broad or very narrow we've chosen
to go very narrow with our Focus so
we're only focusing on methane
mitigation we're only focusing on
landfills and then even within landfills
we're only focusing on the ones that are
currently venting all of their methane
into the air and the reason for that is
that those are the ones that can make
the biggest difference so if we take a
landfill that's currently venting
landfill gas into the air and we can
stop that occurring that has a massive
climate benefit it's going to be
millions of carbon dioxide equivalents
reduced per landfill
and so our philosophy is we want to
start off so we're creating this 400
million dollar fund over the next three
years but starting off small with 50
million and that can be enough for us to
do 32 megawatts so that's around four to
five landfills starting off small we've
got some sites identified we start to
mitigate that and then we achieve scale
afterwards we're also wanting at the
same time to be really helping more
Bitcoin mining companies to come into
the space what we found is that there's
a lot of great Bitcoin mining companies
out there but their major problem has
either been just identifying well what's
a good candidate landfill how do I even
tell the ones that make economic sense
and there's a lot of learning there
we've already done a lot of that
learning so rather than a whole lot of
Bitcoin mining companies having to do
that individually we can help reduce
that learning curve so we're actively
encouraging people through an
accelerated program we've just recently
launched to start moving into the sector
so what we're doing is really pairing up
three things so the capital the Bitcoin
Miners and the ideal candidate landfill
sites
when you think about five ten years from
now
could you all be behind 30 40 50 of
these landfill uh operations do you
think that it's you kind of you know
have the bullhorn you get people excited
about this and then you need a bunch of
other people to kind of run alongside
and and it's kind of more teamwork how
do you look at how this plays out yeah
very much teamwork here we certainly
don't want to be doing this alone uh
there's a lot we can do with one fund
however uh one of the things that's
great about the Bitcoin ecosystem is
that we're on the same Mission and we
all want to cooperate I've literally had
a phone call today with someone who is
very excited about this just talking
about how we could potentially
collaborate uh they're particularly
interested in fled landfills that are
clearing their gas and stopping that
flaring because whilst that doesn't
mitigate quite as many emissions as
Stone reduces some and it's actually a
much simpler proposition in terms of the
amount of infrastructure so we're
talking about collaborating all the time
we we can't say who but we know that one
of the large publicly traded Bitcoin
mining companies is looking to
aggressively move into the space and and
there's also we've got the two existing
ones but we've got a pipeline of about
another 15 Bitcoin mining companies who
are looking specifically there's a
smaller Bitcoin mining companies who are
looking to move into the landfill gas
mitigation space and the more people who
are providing funding to them the more
people are providing Asics for them the
more people who are providing services
help them to gain carbon credits the
more people are helping them identify
the right landfills the better the thing
here is that there are no shortage of
landfills around the world we can't
tackle them all alone so we we welcome
other people come into the space
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find more about the firm
uh so basically for me personally is on
Twitter at dspn
and then you can find out more about CH4
Capital CH4 that's the methane
capital.com uh so those are the two best
ways to get hold of us
thank you so much Daniel I always
enjoyed talking to you I always learned
something uh this is just freaking cool
to be honest uh yeah we think so yeah
we're pretty happy I wish you all the
luck and uh and I'm cheering for you so
we'll definitely do it again in the
future
look forward to account